the first student that we actually had
was actually about 50 yards away from
where we're standing right now which is
kind of a weird full-circle moment for
eSports it was basically one big open
space and we used curtains to partition
the teams from each other from the
broadcast desk I mean the entire
production crew couldn't have been more
than 25 at that time but we were so
proud of it you know we were able to
launch you know the first regular
eSports league in the West out of that
studio and then we moved on and you know
we went to the Manhattan Beach studios
the year after it was actually a movie
theater soundstage so we would have
build out a much bigger stage have the
teams actually in desks kind of like you
see here we're able to bring in an
audience for the first time and then the
year after that we actually moved to
this location so we've been able to
build out this space a little bit but
this is kind of what we feel is at this
point kind of the best broadcast we want
to put on this is you know what we're
able to really highlight the pros give
really great analysis in between the
games build out the right content pieces
we want to build and deliver our great
experiences fans
the na LCS or the North American League
of Legends Championship Series
represents the best League of Legends
teams in North America every weekend the
crowds show up in real life to enjoy the
games and hundreds of thousands more
fans tune in online the popularity and
success of the LCS broadcast is raising
the bar
today we're going behind the scenes at
the LCS arena to see what it takes to
put on one of the best productions and
competitive gaming on any particular
gameday we've got about a hundred and
fifty people who are participating in
the show and then there's probably
another 20 to 30 people who are working
behind the scenes who are not here on
the weekends but are doing all the prep
work to make sure that everything
everything actually happens everything
that happens someone had to do that what
camera are we watching okay well someone
told someone to grab that camera someone
switched to that camera someone's
Manning that camera cool to grab my
strobe okay someone made that graphic
someone wrote what was on that graphic
so when research was on that graphic and
someone put the button put that guy
Africa on camera
okay cool within one scene eight people
done stuff I am an eSports interviewer
and League of Legends expert I guess you
could say I've been covering the space
since 2011 it is crazy to see how hard
everyone at the event is working the
casters and the production crew work
days in advance to make sure that
they've got like the right show at the
beginning the storylines that they're
telling are honest ones to have stats
and interesting stuff to bring up that
really help the audience understand like
who is the underdog in any scenario or
who is the advantage team when the game
is live everything's improv everything's
off-the-cuff we're talking and
describing what we see but the little
intro bits we at least have bullet
points where we're bringing up things
like hey here's what you want to look at
this team's got this record right now
and here's what's going on with this
will always be slacking each other
saying hey what are you gonna talk about
this game what do we want to get out of
this game as a whole oh you want to
touch on double of stats I got you there
we got your full D sheets and whatnot
that you look up and say okay we'll have
this this this and this happens then
those are tie breakers for our game days
we'll all meet up at the CLG office and
then on the van ride over it's really
quiet
well I'll be listening to music and then
I always have like a ritual like going
to the bathroom and I'll just like kind
of like meditate and like relax in there
for like 10 to 15 minutes if I can wake
up I can listen to some jazz some calm
music know I have an hour to myself do a
few you know monolith
I mean they they because they
immediately you see Mauna LOA's I'm
gonna lose ooh do all the funny stuff
you would never do in front of somebody
else like face and you go at it and come
in shout with all my friends all my
co-workers if we have read through that
day we do read through make sure that
rings you know in place do our normal
rehearsals make sure everything works
log in the tournament row make sure you
expect at a game from there typically
we'll go behind the scenes we'll go to
the catering area which is where they
bring in they've got food for everybody
behind the scene and then after that we
go to everybody goes to makeup everybody
goes to wardrobe
I start with awfully for the guys are
still in rehearsal but they always end
early so as soon as they get out they
come check in here
some people want kind of a distraction
for a minute while they're here because
it's kind of a little break from from
prep and others just want to get back to
that prep as soon as possible but if
they're nervous and more excited and
talkative then we'll like joke around
with them sometimes I'm joking around
with Haunter and sometimes he he has his
ear buds in and he said he's in the zone
and darshan will come in and sometimes
he has his ear buds in too but other
times we can get him to sing for us
cause he likes to sing a lot I think
something interesting audience doesn't
know is that the make up room is like
right below the fans so like while we're
like getting makeup done and getting
ready for the game I can hear like the
casters and the fans like right above us
like going crazy something fans at home
probably only get a small glimpse of is
the the pro player lounge we have a
space where teams can go during the
games before the game is right after the
games it's a great space for them to be
able to congregate and sometimes you get
really good interactions between pro
players who are coming in and grab
catering or a snack or a drink or walk
through to go to the bathroom and you
forget that they're you know maybe
friends or kind of had their own funny
inside jokes so watching them kind of
pass by each other and their
interactions has always been kind of a
really cool thing for me one area that
no one ever gets to see besides the
media really in the pros I guess is the
press room which is upstairs at the LCS
a lot of fans will see the stairs and
you wonder kind of where'd those head -
it's the press room up there there's
interview rooms up there work room
everybody's watching the games and then
we
really lucky to have kind of like a
skybox style window where you can look
out on the arena and see everything
that's happening when we load into the
LCS games beforehand we're sitting in a
lobby we're all 10 players and all 20
spectators and just like in a normal
game of League of Legends when you have
10 players sitting around in a lobby
with nothing to do for five minutes
because they're waiting on it to start
they all start typing sometimes they'll
just randomly like talk trash to each
other usually jokingly and sometimes
they just do weird asterisk
conversations where they say things like
walks over and Pat's you on the head and
weird stuff like that and more often
than not I end up getting a laugh out of
those at least once a day I definitely
didn't think that this is what I would
end up doing but I couldn't have asked
for anything better I get to do makeup
and I get to travel the world which is
all I've ever wanted and it realized
that it would happen
mostly with men and in eSports but I
love it because the energy here is just
so great I still love this game after
all these years I love that I get to
come in and talk about it with excited
fans or interviews about it all that fun
stuff and it's it's just really exciting
getting to still be part of something so
amazing my best vision of the NA LCS
production is that our people continue
to get better they continue to strive so
that the production is better week two
than it was week one better week three
than it was week two and just continue
that absolute hunger that what they're
doing is is never as good as it could be
and we're never kind of hitting the
ceiling in in production quality only
the best teams in North America get a
chance to play on the world stage in the
next episode of this series we're
telling the story of the most ambitious
eSport event on the planet and what it
means for the players striving to get
there
[Music]